ladies and gentlemen thank you for
clicking on this video we got ourselves
another batman clip called i got you i
can only imagine what clip this is from
ah if you haven't done so already
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our review for
the batman is up because we do have an
early screening booked so right now we
are doing a stack shoot of like whatever
clips were sent our way and then we
can't react anymore if anything comes
out because we'll have seen the movie so
if we're uploading it that means we
haven't seen it yet if we're not that
means we've seen it but hit that like
button if you can let's watch a short
clip and then we'll uh talk about a
little bit
oh
psycho
yeah
i'm grateful that we got an early screen
but also i managed to land imax tickets
at amc universal on friday so i'm like
wow look at that there i can't wait to
see that just those additional locked
off shots especially when they're going
up the ramp i'm like damn i can't
imagine how many cameras they had right
while filming this one scene oh it had
to be insane
so visceral the sound design i love how
there's like no music there either you
could just feel the engine and you could
feel the noise in the land around them
in the atmosphere well the elements it's
just all rain and fire and metal
i love it and you have a penguin
calling him the psycho yeah like he's
afraid of him and he's like hey look the
eclipse always stood out in the trailer
yeah they always
that was amazing yeah i can't wait to
see what called for like like they gave
us these tiny tiny tiny little snippets
and each one i just makes me that much
more excited to see
what character he's bringing to the
table with this
guys
you know what to do
leave a like thanks for clicking on this
and thanks for telling us about this
catch you guys soon
[Music]